hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel I guess spoiler warning if
you've not played the loss of his pot -
you shouldn't be here
so it's been like a few weeks since the
game came out right I think I don't even
know what time is anymore
and I generally thought that the
gameplay was a significant improvement
over the loss of his pot what I did have
some other issues with the game but you
know there are other videos where I talk
about all of that stuff so I just kind
of was curious what would happen if I
played through the hospital boss fight
patient zero on the hardest difficulty I
played through the whole game on normal
and while I actually don't think I died
in this fight I think I died in the room
immediately off - funnily enough with
the stalker in there I believe but what
if I played it on survivor I actually
haven't read these what's the difference
an intense demanding challenge resources
are extremely scarce and enemies of
deadly play a amount of damage to play
take some enemies great
well that enemies aggression of enemies
in advancing and flanking complexity of
enemy melee comas that's interesting
movement speed of certain high threat
enemies oh no he could be faster and I
guess allies and stealth won't really
apply him and resources would be
quantity of ammunition and supplies
found in the world just so you guys know
before we like proper proper jump into
this this is pretty much why this fight
kicks off there's like a little bit of
QT right beforehand this is the part
where part of its body breaks off and
the fight like really starts but that
does mean that as soon as I press
continue volume is gonna be real loud I
just did it so how loud it was was like
I should pause and let them know that
let's go
oh yeah no he's Wow already a lot faster
than I expected
my usual running backwards strategy is
probably not going to work here Oh oh my
god okay okay okay I'm I need some
distance on you
no you don't know he's very quick he's
very quick yep okay I'm a lot more
scared than I was
that's the other one fucky-fucky oh my
god stop running at me
oh that's to us that's terrible that's
not a good time for anyone I thought it
was the other side oh my god oh my god
oh my god that's dead up that's dead
there's too much smoke around and I
can't see he's got damn spores uh no we
don't like that Abbi you don't have any
[ __ ] ammo I take that oh my god okay
okay okay okay
duh you're so much faster than you have
any right no no no no no no no oh my god
I just want to change weapons is that
gonna be too hard oh there is that a my
pistol okay yeah let's do this
this is some real Resident Evil [ __ ]
where'd you go family thank you oh well
that holds it at bay Oh thought he'd be
further away oh no I thought he would be
farther on the other side and then he
was right the proximity is the problem
[ __ ]
yeah other ones here Doge Doge Doge Doge
l1l what I want you I hate you both so
much it's really really on my dick right
now
stop running I hate it the most I keep
going the same way where are you big boy
but I don't have eyes on you it's not a
good time for me I'd like to know where
you went please big boy so just like
hard to see because it's only supposed a
really both being hungry no nobody's
company's company speedy so let's be
anything as any right to be no no you're
both people to suckle me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I should not go back there
that's not a good time
all right for a concert come straight
country both of you okay
yeah that's fine go off where is he
where is he where is he
oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh she's right
there
the speed is um yup
how many other lost I need to change
guns
like quite badly need to change guns Fah
please don't have me clone it no
everybody just leave me alone for a
second I've seen me throw up
thank you
ceremonia all right [ __ ] get real
resident evil on this you're actually
it's just wrong
but [ __ ] I would also like to not die
here Abbi I think we can agree on that I
don't know how likely it is
that's good that's progress
[Applause]
okay yeah okay really there's gotta be a
way out of here
that was that was too easy
I mean okay I died several times but I
feel like that should have taken me way
longer than it actually did it maybe
this game isn't that battle supply [ __ ]
okay maybe it's just to be fine let's
try that next room because that's what
actually [ __ ] me up when I first
played it I mean it's not like that
wasn't super intense but I don't know
maybe I a life with playing video games
on the hardest difficulty I kind of
stopped recently where I was like yeah
but I prefer to play more video games
than to just keep playing the same ones
on the hard yeah I'd like to kill you
let's see what happens because this
fight I found it's like Tuffle it's some
help yeah but maybe maybe that that hard
life is what has tainted me here my
expectations
this would suck like as an asthmatic
even looking at this environment makes
me want to wheeze a little bit in my
chest nothing I think most people caught
do that all right you suck and I
remember fighting you being a real pain
in the dick so especially since I have
no ammo let's just do it again I guess
why'd you go [ __ ] where'd you go you
lil [ __ ] it's so funny to me when the
stole cuz think they're being sneaky
which I mean to be fair he did just dump
scare the hell out of me
but it's like dude ya saw you peeking I
saw you
I just dodge everywhere then they can't
get me yes oh I forgot that he could
throw I played like three video games
since this came out dragon it's trying
boss fight pop to kick me in the foot
come on then now please not while I'm
reloading
all right all right okay you like a
button to hit shuts off I feel like I've
done some good shots a lot in the but
really a lot of butt shots it's not
intentional you just run away like a
[ __ ] it's not my fault
stop Charlie's good I'm fine
welcome in
I would also like to he'll know you're
still coming at me I mean I just feel
like it's a risk I feel like it's a
risky hello come on have it coming up
coming up you got it okay and everything
is out wonderful Oh sounded like it
right there but I can't see you so I'm
just gonna panic miss Davies why'd you
go this this is waste area on this
difficulty I feel like maybe I should
have played the whole game on planes is
did that literally just give me one
everything else is out oh my god yeah
know everything oh it did it died
I literally only got one outlet for the
pistol did it die is it gone
did you like slowly bond out somewhere
well that would have been handy whoa I
didn't notice that she only took the
clip huh like somehow never paid
attention to that the whole time I guess
it's dead okay yeah cool does you have
chod corpse you big Chuck verdict
actually not that bad I had a good time
and I feel like I should have played
more of the game that way because it was
like a lot more intense cuz I was scared
well I guess that's it for me today
everyone I sort of expected this video
to be longer but here we are also
friendly reminder ghosts of Tsushima
coverage goes up on my channel tomorrow
very excited to finally be allowed to
talk to you guys about that game so stay
tuned for that
I'll see you all tomorrow bye